are the Republicans where are the decent
Democrats that can see this is this is
insanity Donald Trump is not even a
person anymore he is a symbol he is a
symbol of the average everyday guy that
keeps getting screwed every single time
watches other people
screw up big Banks screw up their
companies and get away with it Donald
Trump has taken Arrow after arrow and
that's why
this is the way the average American
feels tonight and there's going to be a
hundred million people that will walk on
broken glass and Through Fire to vote
for someone other than this corrupt
Banana Republic Administration and
Donald Trump is now a symbol and if they
can destroy him if they can figure out a
way to do this
who else will they come for